little help bro
man gets will follow me right now Baby
Bash no yeah look hi it's a real pity
Pat look Ronnie ray
he finally unblocked you persistence
pays off man I'm not a stalker anything
I don't want to be with him essentially
you just want to be with him like it was
up to beat his crew role like that guy
that had that job for Snoop Dogg blowing
blood
that fool I'm gonna be that guy I'm
gonna be like Gunsmoke you know I want
to be together just you know what he's
like you'd be the guy rollin blunts with
baby bad I want to be the guy sitting
next to him you know when it comes out
of stage he's all sweaty and then you
throw him a towel a knowledge that
mingoes thanksfully thick see that room
you are nipples
maybe batch pre-rolls
and don't order none of those pre-rolls
we don't have that in the budget nobody
here asks for pre-rolls anyway just a
few